he was on NFL Total Access talking about
his love of the Saints when he was
promoting Elias now he's back promoting
the arrangement on E and he's talking
about his love of the Raiders so I guess
that's my first question to my good
friend Michael Vartan who's rescue dog
has played with mine from many many
years what gives Michael Vartan how does
one go from Saint to Raider let's be
clear I was never a a full-fledged huge
Saints fan I I was in a transitional
period in my life I needed to pick a
team uh-huh
because as a kid I was a Dolphins fan
because my uncle was in the Coast Guard
in Miami and he was a huge Dolphins fan
and yeah I just you know the Saints the
fleur-de-lis on the helmet I was born in
France there was a little bit of that
going on yeah but as the French
background so are you a quarter French
like the French Quarter personification
of the French Quarter you don't have an
ounce of French or American blood but no
the Raider I've always liked the Raiders
go back to the 70s it was just such a
bunch of misfits and I liked this Raider
team when they were really bad and okay
and I mean when Derek Carr was just
starting out or you're talking about
before that yeah before that and now
that they're good ish mm-hmm
yeah there's just they're one of the
last teams that I feel still has that
70s spirit in them interesting that well
I mean I miss about football which is
what just back in the day if you played
for the 49ers or the Redskins you would
never ever in your career play for the
Cowboys
you just you know there's obviously free
agency players move all around all the
time like today it's all happening Jordy
Nelson's probably maybe gonna meet with
the Raiders in which case they would
they would wave Mike Michael Crabtree
which is interesting anyway
I just missed that that really that the
hatred between teens I feel like the
Raiders and the Chiefs still might have
it a little bit but yeah I mean the Jets
and the Patriots haven't that's true who
else Brockman who else still has that
old-school 70s and cowboys and Redskins
doesn't mean anything I mean so are you
one of those so yeah I'm trying with
Seahawks and the Niners used to have it
maybe they get it back a little
that anyone with the Bears and the pace
cheating valueless lions Chiefs Broncos
that's a good one that's a good one
Steelers Ravens that's that's that's it
that's it I think you I think you
finally but that's the point
right so you one of those Michael Vartan
here in the Rich Eisen show where you're
watching at the end of the game and
they're swapping jerseys and shaking
hands and smile you get upset with that
sort of I'm not upset with that because
you know most of these guys either play
it together in college and with again
with right they there they all know each
other pretty well but I I'm a fan of the
game first and foremost I love football
so I'll watch any game and I just I just
miss a little bit of the the you know
just that that real hatred for the other
team you know not a personal level
obviously but just that that logo that
color do you have that in your
profession is there anyone in particular
that you particularly despise Michael
that I refused to how much time is there
any such situation no not really you
just take it one show at a time hope for
the best you don't have a crystal ball
it is you know I'm kind of a crew member
trapped in an actor's body I still I'm
trying to figure out what I'm gonna do
when I grow up
mm-hmm I doubt I'll retire as an actor
mm-hmm we were just talking off air if I
could get a job here mmm
you're more than happy that the
arrangement would be my last venture
into the acting world
Sports is my shoe fashion I know that
and it's taken me a long time to have
the courage in a public forum right when
people say what's your passion in life
mmm sports mmm you know because it's oh
you're you're a meathead you're this I
don't care anymore so let's be honest
here based on your filmography and don't
laugh don't laugh
based on your your filmography if a-rod
walked in here would he get jealous of
you
what'd he get jealous with me yeah I
don't think so but you've you've been
with you've been with JLo I well not
really
not technically he's really been with
James his notes are on the are on that
right there on there on the table so you
think it's all good oh I would hope he's
even a-rod
I would think so especially considering
now he's with he's with Jay he's with
ESPN and JLo now they are together oh
did you not know no I did not know that
am I breaking news yes you have you've
been on the arrangement set a little bit
too long no I've been my TV's only team
to sports or Animal Planet that's what
it is
I really care about what's going on in
show biz Michael Vartan here on the Rich
Eisen show so we have for you setup
because you're an old school football
guy MMK you do what would you say how
many of the first few Super Bowls would
you know off the top you had final score
MVP and location what would you say what
would you say you could put on the table
right now I think location I would be
maybe 95 percent MVP maybe a hundred
percent score if he if he bit close all
right let's give him some music here no
there's some NFL Films music to fire
them up Chris Brock but picking random
Super Bowls just no 1 through 15 okay
try that listen Super Bowl one Michael
what do you got the Green Bay Packers
beat the Kansas City Chiefs Los Angeles
Morial Coliseum 35 1035 10 correct dark
Bart Starr in the MVP MVP okay go for it
number two number two - bull to Green
Bay beat the Raiders who 30 33 14
correct 14 whether that was Orange Bowl
correct Bart Starr correct Super Bowl
three you're probably your favorite
Super Bowl yes the the guarantee yeah
Jets beat the Colts 16 to 7 correct Joe
Namath yes Lee that was also at the
incorrect Super Bowl for matriculate the
ball down the field boys just keep
matriculating the ball down the field
it's correct the Chiefs beat the Vikings
this is gonna be tough 24 620 620 373 7
who is the MVP Len Dawson I know where
was it ooh is that Tulane that's correct
Wow in New Orleans go for it Super Bowl
5 Colts beat the Cowboys 1613 rekt
Orange Bowl correct first time ever
defensive player MVP and player on a
losing team was the MVP Chuck Holly
Decker
it's Michael Vartan anything damn near
five four five
alright Superbowl sixer let's go six
Dallas beat Miami I want to say 24 or 27
3 24 3 what was that over there Brockman
do you have that score cuz my computer
yes 24 24 3 and who is this and who was
the the MVP roger-dodger
and where was it I believe it's the one
and only game ever played it rice
stadium is that true
you guys know no rice is coming up oh
this one then this one's again at Tulane
Stadium Tulane that's right all right I
know which it's the Minnesota Miami game
that was at Rice correct correct yeah
this is impressive Super Bowl seven
Super Bowl seven the perfect season
Coliseum mmm dolphins beat the Redskins
14-7 that was the famous Carroll your
premium guess is correct correct fast
return that for the Super Bowl eight
several eight oh it's really dolphins
over the Vikings correct who the score
is gonna be tough this is impressive
twenty nine twenty four seven I don't
know 24/7 that's honestly just a lot
faster and take one last shot at the the
MVP in that game Larry Csonka that's
correct
that's one through eight Wow we could go
on and on amazing Michael Vartan
everybody have a lot of time oh let's
talk about the arrangement sir before we
send you back up the 405 if you want to
hear the max McGee story well what would
you I mean I would rather talk about the
max McGee story but I want to make sure
you're getting your money's worth and
your people who are please watch the
arrangement anyway the max the
arrangement is about what it's basically
a peek behind the curtain of what goes
on in Hollywood and all the wonderfully
manipulative situations that occur and
how careers are made or broken and what
exterior forces are at play that
actually make movies happen or not and
my character plays the head of this
Institute he's very shade he's very
creepy
it was very fun to play and he he
basically has his hands on everything in
the business and it's a it's a really
dark
a really good show a lot of people don't
know it's on e because I think e you
know and justifiably so we still seen as
a platform for reality shows but they're
really branching out into one-hour drama
and this is their second after the
Royals and I really love our show and
Josh Henderson plays the actor who has
the arrangement that you have oversaw
overseen with an actress yes sir I've
seen eventually so they're both
wonderful they're great to work with
LexA Doig plays my wife she's Canadian
she's amazing she's got the filthiest
mouth I've ever heard
fantastic we have a great time making
the show we shouldn't back Hoover and I
think people will be surprised if they
tune in the thing oh wow this is only
you know great I like this fantastic
it's at 9:00 Eastern on Sunday Michael
Vartan you come back anytime sir thanks
for having you come on it's great to see
you again Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience